sometimes if I'm gonna catch a flight I
actually do use an alarm clock so hi
Gabriel ahem playing and I'll be
presenting I'll have what she's having
and other models of behavior some
background about me I started my career
at Neera economic consulting in the
securities practice estimating damages
and analyzing claims and let for you
some litigation this range from topics
such as the fallout from the financial
crisis to product liability to predatory
lending and more recently I started at
chop creative salad company and strategy
and analytics and this is my first time
going to work with consumers and
consumer data so I really wanted to get
a better sense of some of the trends in
the industry and some of the anxieties
that we're all facing today because I'm
not only like a data scientist I'm also
a person a user and a data point so I
wanted to be a little bit more cognizant
about how I was thinking about that so
first we're going to talk about what
some models of customer consumer
behavior would be and then I'll tie that
to some of my experience working with
working with borrower behavior and some
of the intertwined history of
discrimination there and also just
exploring the Facebook platform because
together with Google that accounts for
60% of market share for digital ads in
the US so I thought that was a pretty
good place to start and also their
website apparently has a lot of good
hidden fun facts about some of the
trends going on
so by predictive customer behavior
modeling ultimately I think what
organizations are trying to do is
segment customers based on their
behavior and track them over time
analyzing their purchase behavior in
order to understand if this is going to
be a lucrative customer going forward
especially relative to the customer
acquisition cost and ultimately it's an
designed to make a yes/no decision about
whether or not you're going to engage
with that customer this reminded me a
lot of models of borrower behavior we're
using different factors that borrower
presents
in a loan application and that
ultimately determines whether or not you
think that a borrower is going to repay
a loan some factors may include credit
score alone to value debt to income
documentation employment history and
ultimately the bank uses those factors
to decide whether or not whether or not
you're eligible for a loan and if so
what what they would charge you for it
notably absent on this list or race
familial status and other protected
categories but as going forward we're
becoming more involved with social media
you could use factors outside of these
outside of these established in loan
application factors to predict things
going forward
also banks actually pull these loans
together across a variety of factors
which I think makes sense because if
you're relying too much on one
concentrated exposure for example all
coastal people who want beachfront
property or all people who work for the
Acme car company if there's a bad
climate event or a bad weather event or
there's sales slump and cars then this
could have a negative impact to their
bottom line and also if there's only one
bank or if all the banks are using the
same model then customers might be
limited in their choice or even
awareness of the offers which is what
happened in the history of
discrimination redlining in the mortgage
market where it used to be acceptable to
say that specific neighborhoods were
considered undesirable or risky and this
led to selective redlining or under
investment in minority communities and
that had a convinced cyclical effect
where the under investment also
prevented them from appreciating as fast
in value and during the civil rights
movement the government stepped in and
through regulation and new establishment
of new agencies was able to try to
combat this with new laws and then
crucially in 1975 there's also the Home
Mortgage Disclosure Act
which from the CFPB website I just want
to read requires many financial
institutions to maintain report and
publicly disclose loan level information
about mortgages these data help show
whether lenders are serving the housing
needs of their communities they give
public officials information that helps
them make decision and policies and they
should shed light on lending patterns
that can be discriminatory the public
data are modified to protect applicant
and bar privacy and I think this is
really important because and just taking
a public example from the air package
hamda data can raise a lot of questions
so in one example the Boston Fed looked
into differences in the rate of denial
of loan applications between white
minority borrowers and further
collection showed that for for stellar
applications or for certain as part of
this result was related to the
underlying factors but for the less than
stellar applications it was actually
because when you needed compensate
compensating factors it was the benefit
of the doubt was more often given to
white borrowers and because it's such a
nuanced and complicated story I think
that's why you continue to see
litigation in this field it's hard to
pick apart what's actually an underlying
factor and what's actually
discriminatory and the complaint will
often state that someone was
discriminated against relative to a
similarly situated white bar which shows
that you yourself might not know when
you've been discriminated against or
targeted until you have a full data set
and I think that you can see in specific
categories and this is just hypothetical
if you're just using one one category
FICO score to predict something and APR
is on the y-axis then you're looking to
see if you've been given a different APR
based on your nearest neighbor or some
of somebody who has the exact same
factors as you and every other way and I
think of
your personalized experiences can make
this especially tricky because you might
be different in a lot of different ways
and it will be hard to see if you've
been treated unfairly and I think this
relates to the practice of just allowing
people to present the facts and in the
gala terian fashion so HUD recently sued
Facebook because they had just been
allowing advertisers to target based on
different factors which were correlated
to protected classes and unfortunately
also drawing red lines around specific
geographies which you can see would be
problematic and Facebook developed more
of its anti discriminatory policy and
said for housing employment and credit
they were actually going to move to a
new platform and prevent people from
using specific protected classes for
targeting and hopefully that this would
help alleviate the problem but I think
this also strikes at the heart of the
business model because if you're
reaching people who matter most to you
and you're using all these different
factors they could also be correlated
with some of those protected classes and
it's actually creating a really
complicated environment and I personally
have some personal balance between
privacy and personalization that I
struggle with because sometimes I want
to give people my data I don't actually
want to get ads that weren't targeted
for me and I actually enjoy when there's
some personalized discovery and I find
new products that I find relevant and I
think that it's also a better use of
resources overall when people aren't
being forced to watch ads that they
don't like so it's definitely a balance
but I also don't want to live in a world
where I feel like my choices are
actually being predetermined for me
based on Who I am and I think that as
people are targeting people based on who
they think that we are like it could
also mean that advertisers are buying
for the same users or that everybody's
kind of
using the same model in the same
information in order to push people
towards this or that and ultimately it
could result in herding of people or
herding of companies and both ways I
think when people are too focused and
being pushed in one singular direction
you might not think about where you're
going and just sticking a little bit
more into Facebook's active users so as
of q1 we had 243 million
there were 243 million active users on
Facebook's platform and that made up
about 30 dollars in revenue per user in
terms of advertising revenue and digging
in a little bit more if you just make
like a facebook business profile you can
see some interesting statistics about
that but you see that the audience is
about 200 to 250 million so good that
lends up ads clicked on it's about 16
over 30 days posts liked 13 and you can
see that across America people like
coca-cola that seems to make sense
Pizza Hut Judicial Watch Buffalo Wild
Wings and I wanted to look at some
audiences that I was a little bit more
familiar with so 26 to 28 year old New
York City men and women I noticed that
the men were clicking on ads fewer times
women were slightly median on median
350,000 to 400,000 women were clicking
on ads slightly more than the median for
the US and if you target just looking at
people who also like Apple you can see
that 80% instead of 40 percent 80
percent of those people are using
iPhones and among men they're clicking
on 22 ads now and women are clicking on
27 ads and if you think that says
something about iPhone users I tried a
lot of different things
basically just liking anything means
you're more likely to click on ads which
could either be because you're already
more engaged on the platform or because
maybe they're being better targeted to
you I don't actually know that and I
think that's part of the point and then
I wanted to do some
background on this audience because I
don't know any of you are not that many
of you and it's surprise surprise you
like our studio and our bloggers that
wasn't really that helpful focusing on
in on New York City I got to know that
40 percent of potentially this audience
has a graduate level degree which
probably meant I was never going to
impress to you with any of my modeling
experience you also like [ __ ] academics
say and bam so and I think this is
important because as you kind of get a
better sense of who people are and what
their behavior is going to be you can
start to think about pushing them in
different directions and just taking a
page out of Richard thalers book nudge
in which he's talking about choice
architecture and how you kind of
structure a default choice I struggled
to even answer this question assume you
know how to arrange food in the
cafeteria knowing that you're going to
impact how kids eat so you could either
arrange the food to make the kids best
off ostensibly probably making it
healthier for them or choose the food at
random because you hate liability or
maybe maximizing sale of items or
maximizing profits but the hardest one
was arranging the food to get kids to
pick the same choices they would choose
themselves this seems like circular
logic because I just told you that like
the order of the food matters so that's
a really difficult question to answer
and because it's difficult I think
that's why people organizations would
want to just give the control back to
you and say you know what like if this
stuff is offensive to you if you don't
like this then you can go in and like
manually adjust things the way that you
want them to you can also download your
data but I think if you don't look at
your data in the bigger context of how
people are targeting you then you don't
necessarily have a good sense of what
your data is being used for and so in
conclusion I think that modeling
behavior is really really difficult and
that wasn't because and that's not
necessarily because I think that
modeling is always difficult you can
make a lot of different models some good
or some bad some better some worse
but actually just struggling to define
the terms as society what we think is
fair what we think is choice and what we
think is neutral is really difficult and
how much we value privacy versus
personalization that's really difficult
and I don't think that's going to be
determined by like a genius and lab
somewhere but it's actually something
that we have to discuss and talk about
and also that impact not intent matters
so it's not something that you can hide
from it's something that you have to be
proactive about and more data obviously
means more scrutiny because the more you
know the more you kind of have a
responsibility to act responsibly with
that data and also I feel like the
current environment is very reactive and
defensive about these topics but I think
it's actually really cool to talk about
because we're all learning more and more
about human behavior and uncovering
where things have been potentially
unfair and how we could potentially make
things better and so just finishing with
this which is some Twitter I never knew
about before but knowledge is power and
knowing can be complicated so kudos to
people who are comfortably keeping it
complicated thank you
[Applause]